Poor shit.
Seals, what drives them?
They always have a plan.
And if the plan goes to shit, guess what they have?
Not a good plan.
So in a game like this, where you've got this and you're striking and you're coming in,
you've got to get across, you've got a goal, you've got an objective, you have a plan.
Hey listen, if it comes to me, I'm going to pass it to you, I'm going to give it to them.
I'm old too, but hey, run towards the orange shorts because I think there's a little bit of a gap there.
It could be as on a rugby field, when you take your girlfriend out for a fucking night out,
there's a plan, isn't there?
Because if there isn't, there's no fucking hoochie-coochie after the movie.
Have a plan.
Okay, last one.
Get it, Frank.
Here, let me get a shot of you.
Did you have a perk on or what?
Yeah, you did.
Right here.
Put a fly here, one here, one here, one there, and on that yellow guy.
That's the thumbnail.
Four players on each side here and then four players on the other side.
And...
That's the end of the video.
Thanks for watching.
Bye.